[Music]
[Music]
I wish I was a little bit taller I wish
I was the ball the rubbles I had a
groove
what am I being arrested for my being
arrested for huh you think you're hot
cuz you don't know how good I am at what
I knew I see you come try real hard be a
twelve-year-old pie fight it's not a pie
fight think it through what you love you
got a job for it just in case in case
what I in case you fail in case you
don't work out yes man she's filling
your head full of beer I pump you full
of strength drawing team and I know you
got what it takes you're stalling I know
it that's why I'm here I'm your
cheerleader honey bored
[Music]
don't need to talk about my dad good
take good tape you did it daddy good job
everybody
my dad's not the reason to drink he's
the reason I work
[Music]
you have beliefs I have great things
I got rodeo clowning so I could never
make it in Hollywood could if you start
when I did how do you think infuse to
have my son paid me
how do you think that feels you wouldn't
be here if I didn't pave
[Music]
you